the people of harkive now live a new
reality
their city under siege by an enemy
unseen
and the front line isn't far the Russian
military sits on its northern outskirts
they awoke with a shark in the center of
this city Vladimir Putin's operation is
real not imagined how are you feeling
this morning
[Music]
um
they don't usually queue for the local
supermarket but today was anything but
normal Elena took her prayer book on the
morning shop
if y the competition for petrol and
Diesel is fierce for many are trying to
leave the city
Alexandra and her partner began to pack
after the first artillery shells hit the
city we woke up at five o'clock from
this hits yeah yeah and we were very
stress and worried so we didn't have
enough time to take to take this clothes
or something like that just the most
important things even I don't know if I
took everything important or but may God
help me and may God help all of us this
only one thing what I can say there are
cues everywhere for shops supermarkets
pharmacies and the occasional third of
our artillery here in the city's
Northern suburbs
incoming shells and they're not far away
the Ukrainian Army has taken up
positions on the city's outskirts but
their personnel are badly outnumbered
the Russian military crossed the
frontier through multiple checkpoints
and shelled this residential
neighborhood in a place called chihuyev
the fire service said a boy was killed
in the attack
this country knows the price it is
likely to pay and the people of hakif
are getting prepared
the largest line we witnessed was formed
by those who wanted to give blood
is
[Music]
foreign
took us for a tour he said he hadn't
seen it this busy since the beginning of
the conflict with Russia in 2014.
I'm just doing my job he said the heroes
here are those who give blood
at the central train station
life-changing decisions are made in an
instant
City residents Alina and Yuri will seek
shelter in neighboring Poland and they
worry they'll never returned
John Sparks Sky News in Hawkeye eastern
Ukraine